a new shipment comes in every [__]
day
[Music]
[Laughter]
zigzag our way
[Music]
it's gonna be one of those nights
[__] it could get ugly hospital
bills will be paid the pigs on the wing
if you undead pain hang up now it's
gonna get ugly in this [__]
tonight and then I want no [__]
children with Chinese eyes want me right
it's gonna be a good night if you're
under 18 hang up now cuz yeah there
ain't no coming back from this
look what I'm Dion call Joey for getting
high before he was 18
look at that cloud of [__] death
coming your way you don't think that
comes out of there's hail balls filled
with THC it'll knock you out like a
[__] chuckling doubt right hook you
understand me you gotta have a real neat
when you're on the streets you gotta be
able to pick up that easy meat and say
oh this could get ugly tonight the
saltwater taffies are back
[Music]
you're like where the [__] is uncle Joey
yeah
right here [__] up is front and center
it's your lucky night cuz I'm in a good
mood [__]
I'm catchment but every day I hate one
more [__] you understand me
it could be you but hey anyway what's
happening you bad [__] uncle
Joey here for a preacher CH sorry about
last night
Pauly Shore went off the deep end and
[__] it happens I got like three notches
now we got like twenty two notches
people don't know when they enter the
Voodoo Lounge what they're gonna walk
into it there's like walking into
[__] Cambodian seventy-one shits
going off in this [__] but it's
unusual night we got two bags of stars
left are you gonna help us eat them no
what the [__]
[Music]
vote for Hillary anyway
Uncle Joe we're here with my best boom
by the flying Jew hydration with TAC
equals winning you understand me
you ready for fun Hindley what the [__]
what's a Monday night without a bong it
it's like a [__] Saturday night
without a black dick for a chubby girl
with blonde hair you know I'm saying
anyway if we're gonna go deep we're
gonna go deep [__] because that's
how we do it here on the pre church
[Music]
if you're an amateur hang up now this is
like a [__] scary ride I'll call away
[__] this ain't Six Flags this is the
uncle Joey [__] FUBU lounge of debt
who asked you tuck suckers nice thanks
flag who gives a [__] I'm sure you do
and you gave me that halo ice cream oh
Jesus Christ weak it tastes like [__]
water with [__] 300 calories for the
whole [__] thing the only problem is
you could meet the whole [__] thing
if you wanted to I know you do because
you like shitty food and figures it's
good with milk for the nights all I need
it for for the [__] protein shakes
that dope them up a little bit no it's
not like a [__] ice cream at all it's
like ice water there's no such thing as
healthy ice cream if you're walking on
ice you might as well dance you're gonna
show up with ice water on a cone I'll
stab you in the [__] neck card second
this little [__] budget that's a little
[__] violence like what comes out of
a [__] a sponsor chop night insane let's
go deep [__] you dislike zombo's house
give it a sampling ever hears I what do
you think of Zombo anyway let's go this
is the [__] but is this tonight this is
it ready there's the part of the [__]
song
that's always taking me apart right here
this guitar solo if I tell you once I
tell you a million times there's one of
the greatest guitar solos because you
can feel the [__] pain and David
Gilmour's
[__] arteries you understand me you
could feel it and that's a couple people
could do that some people play the
guitar some people give it to you right
from the [__] heart
[Music]
you didn't listen
with [__] all you need is a [__]
number to bag H right now and some chick
sucking your dick and you're on your way
out
[__] everybody says suicide for
[__] [__] you it's a little Isis
heroin and some chick blowing your flute
forget about it with an ice cube in your
[__]
here we go [__] what Eddie if
this in the house ready for the [__]
here we go [__] you you have some
oh [__] oh [__] there he goes this is it
they go Lea this is the one [__]
all the way all the way Charlie for you
[__] sat at home
Sidney take a chance Columbus dead
[Music]
that's the ISIS weed they delivered it
this morning
that's what Isis gives the concession
stand when they want to blow some up as
[__]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[__] [__] what the [__] just smoke
this this [__] that killed Nixon I'm
saying oh oh he imagine your room you
want some [__] nobody can also this
guy won't shut the [__] up like this I
don't need this aggravation Joey I'm
hearing things there's black people
jumping up and down in my bedroom I
don't need this [__]
[__] it sometimes you gotta kick the
meal old-school
sometimes you gotta kick the mule
old-school
you thought we couldn't bounce back you
thought we couldn't do it here we are
3000 [__] miles what's that movie
90,000 Leagues Under the Sea member the
kids I'm an old [__] man
[Music]
there you go [__] wife [__]
watch when you could do get them saying
now we're gonna go into the underwater
Taffy's here these the least favorite
and we got some stars of death day like
a little mingle mix tonight insane some
saltwater taffy and some stars of death
that's how we do it in you want to [__]
around go somewhere else gonna watch
[__] now what's that yawning watch
these [__] people
what's the other one they watch on CBS
with the nerds of [__] go watch The Big
Bang Theory's if not this is the Big
Bang shut the [__] up this is the Big
Bang [__] Theory ready you want the
Big Bang Theory you eat this
conglomeration of [__] start
I say six days nothing look at this
[Music]
like that I swallowed the whole [__]
thing I'm like a hooker on sandals I'm
saying I swallowed the whole thing
[__] gotta admit I'm a little bit
confused no nothing
sometimes it seems to me being [__]
around you understand me go that open
collaboration a woman like this you take
the [__] thing you look at it you go
like a Cuban [__] seal so got some
paper on it but I don't give a [__] you
believe somebody's pushing their paper
on it no big deal you don't tell them
you just eat the paper like a savage
[Music]
things right that monkey a piece breaks
and it stays in the car you ever see it
stays a little monkey the cloth what are
you gonna do I pull it out and embarrass
them no you just ship that [__]
up pull up a [__] on it well you think
it tastes like Chinese food you [__] one
down one to go
these [__] people never a [__] with
toilet paper on it
what's the world comin to you I'm saying
you never look the woman's clip with a
tampon and you jiggle the tampon that's
a party right there you pull it back and
forth making suicide in a little inside
when you lick the [__] it's all over but
the shouting yes you can you lick the
[__] and you pull the tampon and then
when the party blows Jesus pull the
thing out like a [__] like a [__]
fourth of July rocket insane it's
getting deep in here and we're talking
about eating [__] with toilet paper
what the [__]
there's a family show Joey my sons are
watching this [__] what what what what
I'm a taxi to eat nicely what's going on
we'll get boats on fire
[Music]
you believe this button yet fine I
believe that [__] I know people send 50
songs and swallow a dick I'm fine with
chlamydia on it in their throat don't
[__] it hurt this guy's dick bong it's
up ahead
you bet I do a big [__] you [__]
how to fire the same difference and you
think that [__] my job is easy I just
show up people giggles no [__] I
gotta work it in seven days a week
24/7 never [__] around why I wet
because my hands are sweaty I don't
[__] know just live with it eat the
[__] things and stop asking questions
run away it's a thousand questions this
[__] this guy bumps into a trash and he
starts asking questions and how many
people want to bump into a
conglomeration of stuff
the only people ate that whole
conglomeration like that he said I deal
with anyway youtube.com slash Joey Diaz
last see something like that who was a
run of the house
full of pain
who was taught not to spit and the fan
I'm saying with rapper not yet who was
told what to do by the man are you
[__] kidding me this is Floyd with
like 70 [__] cent go listen to it jump
out the window
is as good as it [__] gets Gilmour
waters the whole [__] horrible
everybody's doing acid doing everything
metal and that hoop I'll do anything for
him the pat on the back oh [__]
who was wasted away this [__] ice
weapon
yeah
look example I already ate done I'm not
sweating I'm hanging inside for a bumpy
let's give that a break come back and
then you go back here we go by the [__]
in the end youtube.com / c / Joey Diaz
that's the place to be [__] don't
let him tell you that Mel st. Lazarus is
here it's going out that's that last
bars would often work what's going out
with that last day
the Funky Jesus Grayson's gonna help you
to Monday night Jesus Christ can't help
nobody the Monday night who was dragged
down by the stalls we [__] around so I
understand oh look I found it my baby
conglomeration 125 these are nothing
these are baby pills this is what you
give you four year old when he has a
cold [__] we got [__] stars here [__]
are you kidding me and you wanna go to
rehab
don't do it now doing next week when the
bags of God you think you gonna rehab
when the drugs are gone and your
mother's dead and there's no more dough
left you know I'm saying you can't snort
the dirt around the house that's when
you go yeah right now we still have
drugs left greetings from the savage
look at this [__] wait me yes
all this look at this [__] thing
what's this throat what's going on over
there me anyway I'll meet no me you
still got a conglomeration there's at
least half of that cuz I'm only the
stars like a savage by myself you
understand me that's what Monday nights
are about if you're gonna [__] around go
somewhere else but if you're gonna
[__] go deep with us tonight we're
here we're here we're queer the song is
over 10 minutes youtube.com / c / joey
be ready for bong hit lee let's do this
[__] one more bonding for you put your
dirty fingers in your mouth
yes you can
it's a caffee what the [__] just swallow
the goddamn thing
yes I you understand me not only am i
babysitter [__] him here I gotta
watch him now a good [__] babysitter
he understand a babysitting you remember
for life when a babysitter gives you
drugs or licks your nutsack when your
[__] for you remember that [__] -
you're 28 you understand me you're
looking on face book deal on her name
whatever used to call it you believe
this book basilar cranking up that's its
bumps on his head from all the edibles
can you believe that we got some we got
some liquid acid we got some paper
answers we got everything already
you got sugar cubes oh my god that was
great it's terribly yeah you can't be
doing [__] ass in the daytime you
gotta wait till it's dark out anyway
leave you ready for a bong and what
let's do it it's time to take it down
the hatch come in cut second I'm
watching you like a hawk well he was
about four I won't know what I picked
them up yet myself I got nice eyes and
they bounce up and down your leg for
five hours
let's go that's lucky so far you're a
babysitter who licks my balls let's go
let's go
and don't be pulling away Eve I know you
look a little in that look not burn my
eyebrows no eyebrows let's go second
don't go nowhere don't go nowhere see
that's what you do it pay you go there
you go there's someone that's the one
that killed Kennedy that's the one
that's the best of booth that's the
Wilkes Booth
go ahead there you go hold it hold it
you two same people beautiful night to
be alive youtube.com slash C / Joey Diaz
that's the place to be if you don't
believe me go ask somebody [__] I
love you
don't forget st. Louis helium Thursday
Friday sadly I don't give a [__] if
you're driving from Chicago Nashville
get that Thursday night it's all low but
the Shelton I got a mule with stars on
the way the st. Louis and Kansas City
just in case if my plane gets delayed
you I'm saying that's how we're rolling
tonight I'll see you guys in the podcast
a black